- So I'm really excited to welcome
Dr. Joseph Scalice here today.
Dr. Scalice is currently a visiting fellow
at the Saw Swee Hock Southeast Asia Center
at the London School of
Economics and Political Science.
And he specializes in the history
of revolutionary movements
and authoritarianism
in Southeast Asia with a focus
on the post-war Philippines.
He's a very prolific scholar.
Since completing his PhD
in Southeast Asian studies
at UC Berkeley, my Alma Mater,
by the way, where I did my BA,
at where he completed his PhD there
in 2018 at UC Berkeley, he has published
no fewer than eight peer
reviewed journal articles,
including, but not all of them,
I'll say, just of the most recent ones.
In 2021, I guess, forthcoming still,
A Deliberately Forgotten
Battle: The Lapiang Manggagawa
and the Manila Port Strike of 1963 in the,
coming out in the Journal
of Southeast Asian studies.
2021, again, Cadre as Informal Diplomats:
Ferdinand Marcos in the Soviet
Bloc, 1965 through 1974.
That's in History and Anthropology.
And also in 2021, this year,
The Geopolitical Alignments
of Diverging Social Interests.
The Sino-Soviet Split in the
Partido Komunista ng Pilipinas,
1966 to '67 in Critical Asian Studies.
He also has a book manuscript
under contract with
Cornell University Press.
It's called, "The Drama of
Dictatorship: Martial Law
and the Communist Parties
of the Philippines,"
which should be coming out
probably in a year or so.
And a whole slew of book
chapters, published reviews,
and a lot of wonderful things for everyone
to look up and start reading immediately.
I won't say more because we're going
to learn a lot from the talk,
and hopefully we'll have
a great Q&A after this,
but please join me in
welcoming Dr. Joseph Scalice
to our Virtual Brown Bag series.
His talk today is entitled:
The Geopolitical Alignments
of Diverging Social Interest,
the Sino-Soviet Split in the Philippines.
Please take it away, Joseph.
- Thank you very much, Eric,
I appreciate the introduction.
I appreciate the opportunity
to address the audience
on a topic that I think
is really exciting,
which is to say the Sino-Soviet
Split in the periphery,
not in the core disputants of
the Soviet Union and China,
but in, throughout the
global south in particular,
and the Philippines as a case study.
The listeners may have noted
that the topic of the talk,
The Geopolitical Alignments
of Diverging Social Interests
corresponds with the title
of an article published
earlier this year in
Critical Asian Studies.
I'm expanding upon that article towards
what is a second book proposal
that I've recently submitted.
I have a forthcoming book
with Cornell University Press,
which I hope will be out next year,
on the subject of martial
law and the role played
by two rival communist parties,
which I've entitled, "The
Drama of Dictatorship."
It's an extraordinarily
heated and exciting
and terrifying development
from 1969 to 1972,
as all of the various factions
of the ruling elite are angling for,
in one in one way or
another, authoritarian rule.
And two rival parties, two
rival communist parties,
tied to Moscow and Beijing,
played a critical role in this,
and that's what my book documents.
But it raises inevitably a question,
why were there two communist
parties, and not one?
And why were they, what
were their allegiances
to this dispute between
China and the Soviet union?
And that is what I'm attempting
to explore in this talk,
and in my second book,
which I have submitted
the book proposal for,
which I've entitled, "Aligned Rivalries:
The Sino-Soviet Split From the Periphery."
And the question that occupies me is,
how was it that the political
rivalries in the Philippines,
and throughout the global south,
throughout what I'm calling
the periphery to this dispute,
how was it that they
aligned with the interests
of Moscow and Beijing, of
the Soviet Union and China?
And I'm trying to avoid narratives
that either implied
that it was the product
of external machinations effectively,
the argument of the right,
that these were agents
of the Soviet union or
China, or what I find
to be an equally, say a
dead end, scholarly, is
that these were the product
of domestic disputes
and really had nothing to do
with international communism,
that as I will demonstrate in a moment.
That argument simply does not hold up.
So that then is the origins of this talk.
And I'm going to be examining the role
of the Philippine Communist
Party, and why it was
that it split along the lines
of the Sino-Soviet dispute.
There's been very little
written upon this topic.
The question of why in the 1960s,
in 1966 to '67, in particular,
the Philippine Communist Party,
Partido Komunista ng
Pilipinas, split in two,
and out of this emerged
the new communist party,
the Communist Party of
the Philippines, CPP.
And so while the names are
simply Tagalog and English,
and mean the same thing, for our purposes,
in this talk, the PKP, the Tagalog name,
the older party, is the one
that allied with Moscow.
And the CPP, which still
exists to this day,
and is a strong political influence
to this day, is the party
that was founded in 1968-69,
and allied with Beijing, with
China, so the PKP and the CPP.
But throughout the
first half of the 1960s,
there was but one party, the PKP.
And the question is, why
did it split in '66, '67?
What led to this?
And how do we account for the fact
that it corresponded to
the Sino-Soviet dispute
in a way that is
intellectually satisfying?
There has been very little
prior scholarship on this.
The most influential explanation
was not even published.
It's an unpublished paper
delivered, I believe in Canberra,
the ANU, by a man named Francisco
Nemenzo, Dodong Nemenzo,
a very influential intellectual figure,
a man who was himself a leading member
of the central committee
of the PKP at the time,
and went on to become President
of the University of the Philippines.
And in 1984, he put
forward this explanation.
The schism was not a local expression
of the international dispute
between the Soviet and Chinese parties,
but the offshoot of a generational rift
between the remnants of
an aborted rebellion,
I'll get to that in a moment,
and the new elements who were
spared the trauma of defeat.
So, on the one hand, these
remnants of the Huk Rebellion,
which I'll talk about in a sec,
and these newer layers, the youth,
who came into the party
and were spared the trauma
of the defeat of the Huk Rebellion.
That, he argues, is
the seeds of the split.
But since it occurred at the
height of Sino-Soviet dispute,
what was a domestic quarrel assumed
an international dimension.
Neither the Communist
Party of the Soviet Union,
nor the Communist Party of
China were initially involved.
Their interventions, which
came later, aggravated
rather than triggered the conflict.
Now I see Nemenzo's
Intervention in 1984 as
something of a salutary contribution,
despite the fact that I
fundamentally disagree with it.
He was pushing back against
the standard narrative
that, put forward by the right and agents
of the state and the Marcos dictatorship,
this is still the reign of
Ferdinand Marcos in 1984,
that the split and the allegiance
of the rival parties was a product
of external agents, external machinations,
that these were effectively
agents of foreign powers.
And he's saying, no, this
was a domestic dispute.
But it is not, I argue, convincing
or intellectually satisfying
on a number of levels.
One, it cannot account for
the extraordinary simultaneity
of this in which parties around the globe,
in Latin America, in India, in New Zealand
and Australia, et
cetera, all of them split
within years of each other
along the same lines.
There is a sort of nationalist
myopia to this argument
that sees this as a domestic dispute.
And so while the pushback
against the argument
of agents is a healthy
one, the alternative
that is posited, a domestic dispute
that took on international
coloration, is unsatisfying.
What is more, the idea
of a generational rift,
does not hold up to scrutiny.
Many of the older layers who had been tied
to a peasant rebellion in the 1950s known
as the Huk Rebellion, which was defeated,
many of these older layers
in fact gave their support
to the new CPP, allied to
the Chinese Communist party.
And in the same fashion, the
majority of the party's youth,
who did not go through
the sting of defeat,
remained tied to the PKP, the majority,
including Nemenzo himself,
who was a man of the same youth
as those who broke from
the party to found the CPP.
The argument doesn't hold
up on a number of levels.
Finally, there is the claim
that the dispute was simply one
over violence, this is
not a scholarly argument
so much as a common conception.
The CPP advocated armed
struggle, the PKP opposed it,
this again is fundamentally wrong.
The PKP had an armed wing just as much
as the CPP did, and the
armed wing carried out
guerrilla struggle and bombings.
This was not the divide, what was?
What accounts for this
alignment of interests
between the Soviet Union and
the PKP, the CPP and China,
as well as with rival
factions of the elite?
And how do we account for the simultaneity
of the Sino-Soviet split?
I am inspired in this by something
that I was reading over dinner,
as you read other scholars
from other fields,
and I was reading
Braudel, and Braudel wrote
in his book, "Out of
Italy," of the dialectic
of the internal and external
of the Italian Renaissance.
And he noted that it is sometimes said
that light shed from
the margin is the best,
that a complex whole
may best be apprehended
from its outer limits, in a situation
in which every fact, every
event has been minutely studied
by the generations of devoted historians,
the vantage point of the periphery,
of the diaspora, can provide new clarity
to developments in the core.
Now, I find this particularly useful
for examining the Sino-Soviet split.
The development of global
Maoism, the development
of international Communism
from the vantage point
of the core disputants has
been meticulously analyzed.
What I would argue has been seriously
under studied is that this was
an integrated international phenomenon.
And that the periphery, that is to say,
parties around the globe,
split along the lines
of the Sino-Soviet
dispute, not as some form
of collateral damage, blow
back, an unintended consequence
of a dispute between two
national entities, but rather
as a product of a coherent
integrated international whole.
And that by viewing
the Sino-Soviet dispute
from the periphery, we
can gain new insight,
not only into the disputes
within the periphery itself,
but to the development of global Maoism,
to the character of the global Cold War,
and to the nature of the dispute
between Moscow and Beijing in
the 1950s, 1960s and 1970s.
At the core of my argument is the claim
that Stalinism is, it's a
number of things, this term,
but among them is a
coherent political program.
I think most commonly
in everyday parlance,
we associate the word Stalinism correctly
with the brutal excesses
of the bureaucracy
under Stalin, and also under
Mao, responsible for purges,
for the Gulag, for the
revision and rewriting
of history, et cetera, all of the things
that we associate, I think,
with the name Orwell, et cetera.
These things are true, but I argue
that they are necessary manifestations
of a core political program
and by examining this program,
we see that there is in fact,
a fundamental continuity
between Stalinism and Maoism,
and that Maoism, I would argue,
is not something separate
from, but is a variant of Stalinism
under particular social circumstances.
What then is this political program?
Well, I break it down into
four very simple points.
Socialism in one country,
a two stage theory
of revolution, and the
Bloc of four classes.
These were the programmatic
nature of Stalinism.
You can see here, the artwork
of the Communist party
of the Philippines produced in the 1970s
that shows the bloc of four classes.
I'll get back to that in just a moment
to explain this illustration.
Stalinism at its essence expressed
the political interest
of privileged layers
of the party bureaucracy
within the Soviet Union,
and after 1949, in China.
Seeking to defend and
expand the social basis
of their positions, these
bureaucrats put forward
a nationalist program
of building socialism
in one country as the
paramount political task,
rather than world socialist revolution.
Looking to secure diplomatic
and trade relations
and service to the construction
of their national economies,
Stalinist bureaucrats
sought political capital
with which to negotiate
with a ruling class
in countries around the world.
To this end, they rehabilitated
the old Menshevik line
of a two-stage revolution.
They instructed Communist
parties around the globe
that the tasks of the revolution
in which they were engaged
were not yet socialist
in character, but were
national and democratic only.
A section of the capitalist class,
they argued, would play a progressive role
in this necessary first stage.
So the tasks in this first
stage of a two-stage revolution,
the national democratic stage,
still have a Capitalist character,
and therefore a section of
the capitalist class will play
a progressive role, that's the argument.
The goal of Communist party
leaders should thus be
to secure an alliance with
this progressive section
of the national bourgeoisie,
and to bring the pressure
and support of a mass movement
behind their elite allies.
Now, this is what we
see in the illustration.
This is from a book on how to use drawing
to instruct the masses, and you can see,
on the top layer, mga kaaway, the enemies.
And the enemies are Uncle Sam,
the imperialist United States,
the Comprador Bourgeoisie,
the fat capitalist up top,
and the landlord, panginoong maylupa.
But on the bottom, we see
the bloc of four classes.
And this is comprised of
friends, mga kaibigan.
manggagawa, the worker,
magsasaka, the peasant,
peti-burgesya, some of these
hardly require translation,
it's the petty bourgeoisie,
and pambansang burgesya,
that is to say the national bourgeoisie.
These are the four progressive classes,
and notice that a section
of the capitalist class is,
by this definition, progressive,
an ally of the workers.
A section of the bosses
is an ally of the workers,
that's the critical
point in this first stage
of a two-stage revolution.
Stalinism was first and
foremost a political program
that articulated the interest
of the ruling party bureaucracies
before it was denounced
by Khrushchev in his '56 Secret Speech
of show trials, purges and
the cult of the great leader.
At its essence, it was a program
before it was these other things.
These were the mechanisms
routinely employed
by Stalinism to maintain
a bureaucratic hold
on power, but they were not the essence
of what was disseminated around the globe.
The global strength of Stalinism rested
on the appeal to a layer of
nationalist intellectuals
in countries of belated
capitalist development
of its core concepts,
socialism in one country,
a two-stage theory of revolution,
and the bloc of four progressive classes.
Many communist party leaders outside
of the Soviet Union
were drawn to Stalinism
because they saw this as a means
of implementing national reforms.
It allowed them to deploy
the banner of Marxism
and use it to win mass
support for industrialization
under native capitalist ownership.
So the program of national reforms,
national industrialization,
the development
of a sort of autarkic
national capitalist economy,
a very much at core concept
of nationalist intelligentsia
in the 1950s and '60s,
required mass enthusiasm
to carry it out, but how
do you secure the support
of workers and peasants for
what effectively is a series
of protectionist measures on
behalf of national capitalism?
It amounts to trickle down economics.
If we can improve national
capitalism, it will float,
rising tide floats all
boats, that sort of logic.
I mean, this is of course
long before Reagan,
but that's the argument, and the answer is
that Stalinism provides.
You can use the banner of Marxism,
of revolution, et cetera,
to dress up the first stage
of a necessary two-stage
revolution as progressive,
and then the alliance
with the capitalist class.
Loans from and trade
with the Soviet bloc were
an additional measure and
furtherance to these ends.
It was for this reason that the PKP,
as I'll detail in just a
moment, gave its support
to Ferdinand Marcos in
1965, proclaiming him
the progressive representative
of the national bourgeoisie.
This is a year prior to the
split in the communist party.
There was a contradiction, however,
at the heart of this Stalinist program.
That contradiction is that
it sought simultaneously
to retain hold over a mass movement,
and to secure an alliance with a section
of the elite, it sought to do both.
It was inevitable that it had to do both.
Its alliance with a section
of the elite was predicated
upon its hold over a mass movement,
that was its political capital.
Under situations of
social unrest, however,
this contradiction became
increasingly unstable,
hard to hold together.
How do you retain hold
over a mass movement
and an alliance with
the elite in a situation
that is becoming
increasingly revolutionary,
increasingly explosive, and
in the context of the 1960s,
this contradiction at the heart
of Stalinism tore itself apart,
diverging social interests that found
that the ideological form
of the national dispute
between the Soviet Union
and China gave expression
to these diverging social interests,
an alignment between this
program and its variance
with diverging interests
at a national level.
This is what I'm going to establish
in a sort of the case
study of the Philippines.
Why, what were the variants
of the Soviet Union in China?
This is my last point under Stalinism.
The Soviet Union and
China were both committed
to the construction of
socialism within their borders
and never merged their economies.
Their divergent national
interests inevitably conflicted,
giving rise to rivalry, then
open split and armed conflict.
The uneven economic development
of the two countries
and their starkly different
geopolitical circumstances
fueled the tensions between them.
Situated behind the buffer
zone of Eastern Europe
and with a fairly stable industrial base,
the Soviet union followed a policy
of peaceful coexistence
with the United States
and established friendly
ties with autocrats.
When Suharto rose to power in 1965, '66,
as we'll see in a moment,
the Soviet union met
with Adam Malik, his foreign minister,
and arranged for the repayment of arms
that the Soviet Union had
supplied to the Indonesian state
and that had been used
in suppressing the PKI.
Relations with autocrats.
That China in contrast found itself,
by the mid 1960s, threatened on all sides,
facing an eminent threat posed
by the U S invasion of Vietnam, 1965,
and the loss of its
largest international ally,
the Partai Komunis Indonesia,
the PKI, again, 1965.
The Chinese Communist party sought
to whip up armed struggle
throughout the region
to diffuse the threat of US Imperialism
to China's immense imperiled borders.
While the Soviet government
embraced Suharto,
the CCP promoted Protracted People's War,
and armed uprising
throughout the countryside
of the world, backed by China,
the Yenang of world revolution.
Now this was not universally
the position of Chinese Maoism.
This was put forward by
Lin Biao in 1964, '65,
became the policy of the
Chinese Communist party
in this period, and was
abandoned in the early 1970s
as China reoriented and
established relations
with the United States.
But for this brief
window, from '65 to '71,
in the Lin Biao phase of Maoism seen
from the periphery, we
have all of the hallmarks
of what became international Maoism.
The PKP in the wake of the
defeat of the Huk Rebellion was,
at the beginning of the 1960s,
a dormant political party.
It had essentially disappeared
from the political landscape
as a result of this defeat.
The re-emergence of the
PKP was a direct result
of connections established with Indonesia.
Here, the immensely influential PKI,
the largest Communist party outside
of the Communist bloc,
played a critical role
in the dissemination of the ideas
of the Sino-Soviet split
throughout the region.
And I substantiate this in great length
in the book manuscript that
I'm currently working on.
The ties with Indonesia, between Indonesia
and the Philippines, and how this played
an instrumental role in the dispute
that shaped island Southeast Asia known
as Konfrontasi in the
period of 1963 to 1965.
The Philippines actually
was a core disputant,
something that has been largely overlooked
by subsequent scholarship,
which has seen this
as a national dispute between
Malaysia and Indonesia,
over the formation of
Malaysia, it was in fact,
a dispute over the social
character of the entire region.
The PKI, through a graduate student in,
at the University of the
Philippines, named Bakri Ilyas,
oversaw the rebirth of the PKP,
bringing new blood into the party.
Above all a graduate
student from the University
of the Philippines named Jose Maria Sison,
who will go on to become the head
of the newly founded CPP
by the end of the 1960s.
Sison was not immediately,
however, a dissenter.
In fact, he was the foremost
organizational force
within the PKP, instrumental
in their support
for Marcos in 1965, he was a
core figure in this, the PKP.
The tensions that tore apart
the party were not yet present
at the beginning of the 1960s.
One of the things that's most interesting,
I think in studying the Sino-Soviet split
from the periphery is that the model
of a sort of hubs and,
hub and spokes perspective
in which Beijing and
Moscow are the two hubs,
and the spokes reached
from Beijing to Jakarta,
and from Beijing to Manila,
is only partially accurate.
There was in fact a
complex mesh of relations
that ran from Jakarta to Manila,
from Havana to Manila, and from
Manila to Japan, et cetera.
These, the dissemination of
the Sino-Soviet tensions spread
not only from the core to the periphery,
but throughout the periphery
in a somewhat autonomous fashion.
1965 was, not only for
the purposes of my study
of the Sino-Soviet split,
but for the purposes
of world history, a global turning point,
I don't think this has
been adequately stressed
in studies of the 20th century
where other turning points are stressed.
1965, with the deployment
of US troops to Vietnam,
in March, under operation Rolling Thunder
by the Johnson administration.
By the end of the year,
more than 185,000 US forces
were deployed to Vietnam.
And the crushing of the PKI,
the slaughter of hundreds of thousands,
possibly upwards of a million
members and supporters
of the PKI, in the rise to
power of General Suharto.
This fundamentally redefined the region
and world politics, and
precipitated an acceleration
in the development of global Maoism,
the terms of the cultural
revolution shifted
communist party allegiances.
The crushing of the PKI was instrumental
in the Japanese Communist
party shifting it's allegiance
from Beijing to Moscow in 1966.
It also set in motion the events
that led to the Sino-Soviet
split in the Philippines.
It was in the wake of 1965
that the Philippine
Communist party was compelled
to seek out new international relations
that were not mediated through Jakarta.
In the same year, while these
events were transpiring,
it was a presidential
election in the Philippines.
Ferdinand Marcos had recently jumped ship
from his liberal party and
joined the nationalista party,
and was running as their
presidential candidate
against the incumbent, Diosdado Macapagal.
The critical question in
mobilizing mass support
behind Ferdinand Marcos was the question
of the war in Vietnam.
Johnson had secretly reached
out to Macapagal in 1964,
prior to the Gulf of Tonkin incident,
and said that he needed troops
to be deployed to Vietnam
for an upcoming surge in
US troops in the region.
Now, he did the same with
Thailand, Korea, et cetera.
And Macapagal declared that he would
wholeheartedly send
Filipino troops to Vietnam.
This was going to be known as PHILCAG,
the Philippines Civic Action Group.
That's a rather Orwellian euphemism
for the troops being deployed to Vietnam.
And Marcos in 1965 denounced
Macapagal for doing this,
claiming that Macapagal
was an aspiring dictator,
words that history would render ironic,
and that he was a puppet of US interests
and so on and so forth, and
announced that he was opposed
to the deployment of
Filipino troops to Vietnam.
And on this basis, the PKP, which had been
in an intimate alliance with Macapagal,
broke with Macapagal,
declared their support
for Marcos, and campaigned for him.
Central to this was Jose Maria Sison,
future head of the CPP.
Sison organized the support
from the youth wing,
the pakpak ng kabataanm,
for Marcos, a fact
that he has attempted subsequently
to erase from history.
Within two weeks of the election,
and an interview with Stanley Karnow
of the Washington post, Marcos announced,
many of us felt that the
United States was preparing
to withdraw from Vietnam, but now
that the United States has
demonstrated this resolute will
to slug it out, we've been reassured.
And he promised that he would
be deploying Filipino troops
to Vietnam, reversing his
stance within two weeks.
Interestingly, a side note,
but one can't help but note,
Marcos's campaign slogan, 1965, was
that he would quote, make
the Philippines great again.
Right-wing populists are not
a particularly imaginative bunch.
1967, a memo, this sort of
sets the tone for the split.
In a memo from Marshall Wright
of the National Security Council,
to National Security Advisor, Walt Rostow,
he wrote, it would be nearly impossible
to overestimate the
gravity of the problems
with which our next Ambassador
to Manila must deal.
It has become commonplace
for people knowledgeable
on the Philippines to predict
a vast social upheaval
in the near future,
there is widespread talk
that the current president will be
the last popularly elected
Philippine Chief Executive.
There was one more election,
Marcos was reelected.
But this was correct.
He was the last popularly elected
Philippine Chief Executive until 1986.
Many high-level American
officials considered
the Philippines to be the most serious
and the most bleak threat
that we face in Asia.
That's a staggering statement.
Think of what that entails.
1967, the peak of the cultural revolution
in China, Vietnam, the level
of sort of social instability
in Asia, and the National
Security Council is saying
the Philippines is, we got problems.
So this is a period of
immense social upheaval.
Shortly before Wright wrote this memo,
Marcos's forces opened fire
on peasant demonstrators.
They were part of a millenarian cult armed
with amulets and bolos, not with guns,
and killed 33 of them,
in the streets of Manila.
There were protests of
an explosive character.
The first of which took place in 66,
as I'm about to deal with.
It was these social tensions that tore
through the contradiction
at the heart of Stalinism,
at the core of the PKP, and
split it into two rival factions
along the fault lines of
the Sino-Soviet dispute.
In other words, and I'll get back to this
in my conclusion, but
to preview, it was not
either domestic disputes
or external machinations,
but rather the same heightened
global social tensions
that were accelerating
the Sino-Soviet dispute
in the core, simultaneously
was producing social unrest
in countries around the world,
Paris of '68, et cetera.
The rise of authoritarian
regimes, Suharto, et cetera,
This period of revolutionary upheaval
and authoritarianism tore
through communist parties
around the globe, splintering them
along the fault lines of
the Sino-Soviet dispute.
It is this shared geopolitical
and global context
of class struggle and upheaval that gave
the Sino-Soviet dispute its
international character.
The protests in the Philippines were,
over the course of 1966,
bound up with the question
of the war in Vietnam.
Young people in the Philippines,
as young people around
the globe, were shocked
by the televised brutality
of America's war,
by the hypocrisies of it, by the trampling
under foot of the national sovereignty
of the Vietnamese people, et cetera.
All of these terms were being widely used
by young people in Berkeley, California,
and in Manila, Philippines,
and every country in between.
The PKP however had not only
supported Marcos in 1965,
they had quietly entered into his cabinet.
Members of the central
committee were working
in the offices of Juan Ponce Enrile,
who was the right hand man of Marcos.
They were reluctant to break with Marcos,
but at the same time, they needed
to retain a hold over the youth
movement, their usefulness
to the Marcos administration rested
in their hold over a mass movement.
If they lost their hold
over the mass movement,
they lost their political value to Marcos.
But to retain a hold
over the mass movement
increasingly required speaking out
against the war in Vietnam,
which required speaking out
against Marcos's deployment of troops.
You're caught in an insoluble conundrum.
Over the course of 1966,
the party was silent
on the war in Vietnam and
its front organizations.
The pakpak ng kabataan, the
young people's organization,
in particular, the
nationalist youth, silent.
They did not denounce Marcos's deployment
of troops, not until October, 1966.
It was in August, 1966,
that the battle lines
for the future break began to be drawn
along the geopolitical fault
lines of the Sino-Soviet split.
In July of 1966, Sison, a leading member
of the PKP and head of the
youth organization traveled
to Japan for the 12th
Gensuikyo World Congress
on atomic and hydrogen bombs.
This is a fascinating historical moment
for the Sino-Soviet
split from the periphery
in a great many countries,
because it was at this seemingly
somewhat innocuous Congress,
a Congress, opposed to the
proliferation of nuclear weapons,
but that was connected
to front organizations
of the Japanese Communist party,
that a number of delegates
from a number of countries
throughout the global south
secretly entered China.
It was in late July, 1966,
the dates are extraordinary.
The Japanese Communist party,
as a result of the slaughter
of the PKI and what they
saw as the CCPs culpability
in this, because the CCP
had recently instructed
the Japanese Communist party similarly
to engage in armed conflict,
broke with the CCP,
and reoriented toward Moscow refusing
to accept the Chinese Communist
delegation to this Congress.
A majority of the
delegations to this Congress,
including Joma Sison,
walked out in protest
and then secretly traveled to Beijing.
They arrived in Beijing
on August 6th, 1966,
the day before Mao had issued his
Bombard the Headquarters
poster at Peking university.
It's an extraordinary moment.
It is the launching of
the cultural revolution.
And for two weeks, as Mao
met with the Red Guard,
all of the delegates of
the future representatives
of the parties that would
split along the lines
of the Sino-Soviet dispute were present.
They were hailed as the
revolutionary representatives
of the proletariat and peasantry,
there was a gathering
staged by Chou En-Lai
on their behalf where
10,000 people gathered
to celebrate them and
sang the East is Red.
It was in this moment
that I think the character
of the Lin Biao phase of Maoism,
the Protracted People's War,
the Yenang of world revolution,
and the cultural
revolution was disseminated
in the wake of the slaughter of the PKI.
Joma Sison took these ideas
back to the Philippines.
Events came to a head when
Lyndon Baines Johnson,
October 24, 1966, traveled to
Manila for the Manila summit.
The goal of this summit, which
was secretly orchestrated
by Johnson, but presented as if it came
from Marcos, was in the words
of the Philippines, repressed.
The entire fire power of
the American delegation
during the summit was concentrated
on changing the complexion
of the war in Vietnam
from an American war to a
war of, by, and for Asians.
Entire thing was orchestrated by Johnson,
staged in the Manila hotel,
the grand dame of American Colonialism,
the on the waters of Manila Bay.
And in a bizarre and macabre coincidence,
an American freighter collided
with a Philippines ship
the day that the Manila summit opened.
And I believe over 60 Filipinos drowned
and their bodies were
floating in the Manila Bay
during the staging of
the Manila Bay Summit,
outside the MacArthur
windows of Johnson's suite.
The youth organizing the
PKP, around Joma Sison,
where finally the muzzle was taken off,
and there was an explosion of protest
outside the Manila Bay,
outside the Manila Hotel
at the Manila Summit, and
it was brutally suppressed
by the police on orders, both from Marcos
and from plain clothes US officials.
In the wake of this, all
of the social tensions
that had been percolating
beneath the surface emerged.
The young people that were
the base of political support
for Joma Sison were looking
to continue to protest,
no longer protesting the Manila summit,
but police brutality, and Sison, needing
to retain this as a base of
his own political support,
sought to corral these protests
behind the program of nationalism.
He delivered a speech at Ateneo University
on December 6th, 1966, in which he said,
there is a need to wage a
nationalist education campaign.
The events before, during, and after
the October 24th incident, reveal to us
how much our government
officials misunderstand
the spirit of nationalism.
Anti-nationalism has so
much poisoned the minds
of so many of our police officers,
and those higher executive officials
who give them the orders.
Now I could go on in quoting the speech,
but Sison's point is,
isn't, he wasn't making
the classic Marxist
point that the police are
the armed bodies enforcing the state
which serves the interests
of the ruling class.
He was saying, look,
they've been miseducated
by empty nationalism, and we need
a nationalist education
campaign so that they understand
that they have a common set of interests
with the protesting youth.
He was not, and this is the
critical point, instigating
the leftward movement
of youth and workers.
He was tail ending it, he was seeking
to constrain it as his
base of political support,
but it was pulling him in a particular,
and increasingly radical direction.
There were consequences as a result.
An investigation into the
police brutality staged
in the Philippine legislature
very rapidly turned
into an investigation of
alleged Communist influence
among the protestors and singled
out was Jose Maria Sison.
You can see him here
from the Manila Chronicle
where he faces prosecution.
The, at the center of this
was the man in the black suit,
Carmelo Barbero, the man who rose to power
as a smuggler, became a legislator,
and was bound up with the
prosecuting of communists
and alleged communists in a
series of witch hunts in 1966.
What's interesting, and I'll
get back to this in two slides,
what is interesting is
that Carmelo Barbero,
while he was the leading voice
attacking alleged communists,
and actual communists, said
to be a communist was a criminal offense.
And to be a communist leader
was a capital offense.
At this point, the
communist party was outlawed
despite the fact that it had been allied
with the former president
and was now allied
with the current
president, there was a sort
of universal hypocrisy in this game.
Carmelo Barbero, the leading
witch hunter, was closely tied
to the opening of ties
with the Soviet Union.
His daughter studied at
Patrice Lumumba University.
Every visiting Soviet scholar that came
to the country stayed in the home
of Carmelo Barbero, the leading
anticommunist witch hunter.
It emerged during these
investigations staged
in the legislature that a
large contingent of students
and professors were
scheduled to travel to China.
Here you see three editorial cartoons,
November 18, November 24, and December 10,
from the Manila Chronicle.
Red China is luring Filipino
students away as a pied Piper.
The Filipino student
is defying his mother,
the department of foreign affairs,
the defiance of mother is
particularly egregious,
on behalf of the sneaky
Mao, hiding behind the door.
And finally, these students
are running rough shod
over the foreign office.
This is actually rather far from the case.
They had been invited, their
visit had been approved
by the Marcos administration prior
to the protests of October 24.
In the wake of the
protest, Marcos shut down
the intended travel and declared
that no one would be
allowed to travel to China,
not even tenured professors
at the various Universities.
But while the Marcos
administration was shutting down
all travel to China, in particular
because of the cultural revolution,
which is increasingly becoming,
the world internationally was
increasingly becoming aware
of the character of the
cultural revolution.
The Marcos administration was,
through other elements in the PKP,
conducting informal diplomacy
with the Soviet Union.
This man here, Teodosio Lansang, is
a very interesting figure.
In the late 1940s, he traveled to China
where he was present for the founding
of the PRC in October, 1949.
He was responsible for
Tagalog Language broadcasts
at Radio Peking before he was moved
to Moscow, prior to the Sino-Soviet split.
He was in the Soviet Union over the course
of the Sino-Soviet split in
the late 1950s, early 1960s.
His return to the Philippines,
in January, 1967 was
orchestrated behind the scenes
by the Marcos administration as a means
of opening informal diplomacy with Moscow
to secure loans from the Soviet Union
and the Eastern Bloc, as well as a market
for Philippine sugar and
other agricultural products.
He was facilitated in
this by other figures,
William and Celia Pomeroy,
former heads of the PKP,
now in exile in London, or in England,
and Rubin Torres, a figure
who was instrumental
in this and played a critical role
in the Marcos administration, a member
of the central committee
of the communist party,
and also a salaried government official
in the offices of Juan Ponce Enrile.
The Marcos administration
had a loyal wing of the party
that was looking to secure
ties with the Soviet Union,
as Marcos was increasingly
making machinations
toward military rule.
In fact, the party, as I
demonstrated in my book,
"Drama of Dictatorship," was instrumental
in facilitating this.
The Unified PKP, with
these wings torn apart
by diverging social interests,
made one last united attempt
at a political campaign
in February of 1967,
with the foundation of the Movement
for the Advancement of Nationalism, MAN.
The function of MAN, unlike, say,
the front organizations
of the party in labor,
or in the peasants, or the youth,
the function of MAN was a relationship
between the various front
organizations of the party
in these sectors with
the national bourgeoisie
with capitalist interests.
This was the culmination
of all of those efforts.
And they worked tirelessly
to create this organization.
This is from the Program
of the Founding of MAN.
The names are small and
they wouldn't mean much
to most of the audience, but if you look
through them carefully,
it's a very interesting mix.
It's senators, congressmen,
neither tied to the
Communist party in no way,
except by a loose alliance.
It's what would be the central committee
of the future PKP, the Moscow wing.
Its central members,
founding members of the CPP,
the Beijing wing, and
its business interests,
the head of a nationwide
chain of pawn shops.
Workers tend to not be fond of pawn shops,
but there you are, pawn shops.
And business interests
tied to banking, et cetera,
all of them merged together
in this organization.
It was in the wake of the founding of MAN
that the party tore itself apart.
Both sides made a scramble to seize power.
The CPP failed, or the future CPP failed,
and was expelled in April, 1967.
They published a statement
in The Peking Review,
in June 9, written on
May 1, that declared,
Mao Tse-Tung's Thought
Lights Up the Whole World,
committed to an uncompromising struggle
against modern revisionism
with the Soviet revisionist
ruling clique at its center.
That was the founding
principle of the CPP,
opposition to modern revisionism.
That is to say the line
of the Soviet Union.
The critical question for
the now expelled members
around Jose Maria Sison,
and it wasn't simply Sison,
there was a sizeable chunk of the party
that was expelled, in the founding
of a new party was the
formation of an alliance
with a section of the ruling elite,
well, the section of the capitalist class.
This was intrinsic to their program,
that bloc of four classes.
This was what was the
critical element prior
to the founding of the CPP.
The PKP had an alliance with Marcos,
Sison sought to retain ties with Marcos
over the space of about six
months after the expulsion,
writing a frenzied
letter to the president.
Again, and event that he
has attempted to bury.
Eventually, however, the
party found new allies
in particular, the figure
Ninoy Aquino, who even
for those outside Philippine
politics are probably familiar
with the tensions between
a Aquino and Marcos.
And it is here that we
see as another element
of the Sino-Soviet split,
and how rivalries aligned.
While figures like
Marcos sought to use ties
with the Soviet Union to
consolidate their hold on power
as they moved towards authoritarian rule
at a time of social unrest,
figures like Aquino,
on the other hand, were
the excluded opposition
in a time of social unrest.
They too sought dictatorship,
Aquino was very explicit
that he would have imposed martial law
if he succeeded in getting into power.
The problem for Aquino was he
needed to be in power first.
In my book, "The Drama of Dictatorship,"
I have referred to these layers
as the conspiring understudies.
Marcos is our lead actor, but there are
the conspiring understudies
who are looking
to remove him and play the lead
role of dictator themselves.
The line of Beijing at
this point, armed struggle
throughout the countryside of the world,
but an alliance with a section
of the capitalist class,
these two facets merged in the interests
of these conspiring understudies,
the restive opposition
among the capitalist class
in a time of social upheaval.
It is in this context that
Ninoy Aquino facilitates
the founding of the Communist party
and ties with the New People's Army
from various former Huk guerrillas.
The founding document of
the party declared armed
with invincible Mao Tse-Tung thought,
the Communist party of the
Philippines will surely triumph
and the Filipino people and the leadership
of the revolutionary
proletariat will achieve
people's democracy first
and socialism next.
It's outside the sort of the confines
of this particular talk,
but my forthcoming book,
"The Drama of Dictatorship"
deals with the next period,
1969, the founding of the CPP,
to the declaration of martial law,
and the machinations of
the PKP, the Moscow party,
which staged bombings on behalf
of the Marcos administration
to justify martial law with the
complicity of the president,
and wrote the documents
justifying military dictatorship.
And the CPP on the other
hand, which directed all
of the unrest and protests
of the time behind Aquino.
When martial law was imposed,
over 60,000 people were
arrested for political reasons
for the first five years
of the Marcos dictatorship.
The majority of these were not Communists.
They were not members
of the political elite.
They were ordinary workers and peasants.
Mao, however, and this is my final slide.
Mao, however, and the interests
of the Chinese Communist party,
because of the heightened tensions
of the Sino-Soviet
dispute, which had turned
into an armed conflict
in the Xinjiang region,
borderlands of China and the Soviet union,
sought the support of Kissinger and Nixon
as a counterweight to the
threat of the Soviet Union.
And reined in Lin Biao
altered the line of the party
from Protracted People's War
to the Three Worlds Theory
in which the Soviet Union
and the United States were
the two first world powers
and were the great enemy
of the peoples of the world, and sought
to form alliances of
his own with autocrats.
This became the policy of the CCP.
And thus with the rise
to power of Pinochet
and the crushing of the
Chilean Communist party,
the Chinese Communist party
immediately welcomed Pinochet
for the Chilean Communist
party had had ties
with the Soviet Union.
In a similar fashion, when Marcos sought
to open ties with China in 1974,
Mao welcomed Imelda
Marcos, September, 1974,
you can see him here kissing
Imelda Marcos's hand.
And Joma Sison, now head of
the CPP, wrote a statement
in the Flagship Publication
of the Communist Party,
heralding the visit of Imelda Marcos
to the Chinese Communist
party, to Beijing,
as a diplomatic victory for
the people's Republic of China,
a victory for the Philippine
Revolutionary struggle.
In 1975, formal diplomatic
ties between the Philippines
and China were opened, Mao
met with Ferdinand Marcos.
Marcos declared, while in China,
that he would be crushing
dissidence in the Philippines.
And no one in China made any
attempt to countermand him.
They would not intervene
in these internal affairs.
And thus the PKP was now in the cabinet
of the martial law administration,
and the CPP was isolated.
The Sino-Soviet split had
split the Communist party
of the Philippines in two,
in a period of increasing social unrest,
and now it was unmoored from Beijing,
but it was set in motion
by the political line
that was articulated from '65 to '70.
By looking at the Sino-Soviet split
from the periphery, we
see a number of things.
One, that it is a shared global conflict
that is leading to these tensions,
that brings about a set
of aligned rivalries.
That this has disseminated, not
simply along hub and spokes,
but through a mesh of ties
throughout the periphery.
It also calls us to sort of reevaluate
the sort of bipolar
narrative of the Cold War.
Ferdinand Marcos was a
critical ally of Washington.
And yet, here we see him
allied to a Communist party
and conducting informal diplomacy
with the Soviet Union from
1965 through the 1970s.
It indicates that, to an
extent, the critical question
for us in understanding the development
of the Sino-Soviet split, and
the global Cold War, is not
to follow the map of geopolitics,
but the map of the class struggle.
For this, I think, is
the decisive question
that underlies the Sino-Soviet dispute
and the tensions that it gave
rise to and that it expressed.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much, Joseph.
This is really a rich
and detailed discussion.
A lot of, a lot of historical
episodes to explore.
So I'm going to open it up
now to a question and answer.
I'd like to give the priority
to any of our guests who are
in the Philippines right
now for the first questions,
because I know that it's very late there.
So if anyone has stayed up
this late to follow the talk,
I'd like to give you the first opportunity
to ask a question.
However, if you want to
wait, that's fine as well.
But the way we'll do this is you can use
the raise your hand function,
and then I'll call on you to
unmute and show your face.
If you're having difficulty
using that, I noticed
there's a lot of people
using the phone option today.
If you have a question and
you can't get my attention,
wait until there's a gap in the speech,
and then just announce
that you have a question.
But let's start with people
who may raise their hand first.
Does anyone want to start
us with a question now?
Joseph, while people are waiting
to formulate their thoughts, I'll start
with a question, a very naive question.
I'm a Southeast Asianist,
but not a Philippine scholar.
And I found your descriptions of Marcos
to be so interesting, you
know, because the way we,
as non-experts imagine
Marcos, it really comes
as a kind of set of caricatures
in some sense, right?
And so I wondered if you
could tell us a little bit
about what your research
tells us about Marcos
and the way in which he
kind of moved effortlessly,
it seems, between all of
these kinds of positions
that seem to be polar opposites
to the rest of us, right?
And one, what does that say
about Marcos as an individual,
but also maybe how does
that reveal something
about these binaries that we often see
as so, such polar
irreconcilable opposites,
but perhaps they're not
really such opposites
after all or something like that.
- Yes, it's a terrific question.
I mean, worthy of a talk in
its own right, I suppose.
It's a common remark, but it's true.
There, a very famous
Filipino author by the name
of Jose Pikakaba, writing
I believe in 1971,
characterized the dispute in the elite
in which one camp was
oriented around Marcos,
and then another around
Aquino and the opposition.
And he said, if one did
have to give this a sort
of class character, one
would see this as a divide
between the enchante and the
nouveau in the oligarchy.
And the enchante is Aquino and company.
This is old established money,
ties to Spanish colonialism,
American imperialism,
many of them leading collaborators
during the Japanese occupation,
large landed estates
and so on and so forth.
The forces around Marcos,
and Marcos himself,
and this is critical to
understanding the psychology
from then, were the nouveau riche.
They were the new industrial
interests and so on.
This is not to say that they
were poorer by any means,
and Marcos enriched
himself extraordinarily,
but they were frowned upon
in the best of circumstances
by the enchante, excluded, scorned.
The enchante, and this is true
of this sort of social layer
around the world,
consolidated its interests
through incestuous intermarriage
and sort of keeping it all
within the family, et cetera.
There's a bit of a weed-eater
noise outside, I apologize.
And Marcos resented
this and brought to bear
in his sort of character, the quintessence
of the nouveau, self construction.
He was forever obsessed with the creation
of a persona and he was brilliant at it,
he was cunning, conniving,
and absolutely brutal.
One of the most famous early
stories from Marcos's career is
that his father's political
rival was murdered in his home,
shot through his head
while brushing his teeth.
And Marcos was convicted of the murder.
And Marcos was put on sentence
subject to life imprisonment,
and then was going to be
subject to the death penalty.
But he was also, at the time, a graduate
of the law school, and was taking the bar.
And while in prison, and this
is a somewhat legendary story.
While in prison, he aced the bar,
getting the number one score
in the country that year.
And wrote a three volume
appeal to the Supreme Court,
asking them to throw out
the charges against him,
which was upheld, not so
much on legal grounds,
but because behind the
scenes, people said,
it wouldn't look good to
have the number one lawyer
in the country subject
to the death penalty.
And so a political deal was
reached and Marcus was released.
This was his rise to national prominence.
Deserved in some ways, but also,
at the same time revealing of the level
of brutality and Machiavellianism
that he would resort to.
He then concocted a
persona by creating a story
of having medals of honor
and so on and so forth.
He would turn on anyone who
was not immediately useful
to him, we see this again
and again and again.
And we see this not only domestically,
but internationally, and
Marcos was extremely able,
not simply at working
with the United States,
but working the United States.
There's a wonderful book called,
"Waltzing With a Dictator,"
by Raymond Bonner,
that demonstrates how the Marcos's knew
the ins and outs of American politics.
They contributed a million dollars,
stolen from the coffers
of the Philippine state,
to the reelection of Richard Nixon.
Amazing, huge contributor, more money went
from the Philippines to
Richard Nixon's reelection
than went from the United
States to Marcos's.
So there's that element,
and while playing that
Marcos was able also to reach
out to the Soviet Union.
I think that persona of self construction
and that willingness to
do effectively anything
in his political rise is
the critical character
of Marcos and the class
interests he represented.
- Thank you, that was fascinating.
I see there's a hand up
from Mathias Phoebeger,
and if I've mispronounced your name,
please say it properly for me.
- Sure, you got it almost
right, it's Phoebeger.
Thanks, Joseph, for what I thought was
a really fascinating
talk, it inspired a lot
of questions from my end, but I,
just to limit myself to one, I wonder
if you could spend a little
bit more time explaining
how the Philippine communist
movement interpreted
the collapse, the crushing,
of the Indonesian Communist movement,
because it seems to me
that it could play out
in one of two directions.
On the one hand, this crushing of the PKI
may discredit the parliamentary
peaceful road to socialism
that had been embraced by the PKI.
But on the other hand, it
may discredit the allegiance
with Beijing that had also
been embraced by the PKI.
So I wonder if you could
just say a little bit
about how that debate unfolded
within the Philippine communist movement,
because this seems
fundamental to your argument
and perhaps quite contingent as well.
- That's a terrific question
because it is such a critical question
for every communist party.
As I mentioned in passing, the
Japanese Communist party had
to grapple with this question
and it precipitated the
shift in their allegiance.
This was true for every
communist party around the globe.
The events in Indonesia
were absolutely shocking
and required an assessment.
Internally, the discussions within the PKP
likely polarized around
opposition to Beijing
on the one hand, and the need
to follow the line of Moscow.
So there was that, but publicly,
it was written by Sison himself,
who became the head of the Beijing party.
Sison, or the Beijing oriented party.
Sison wrote a statement assessing
the events in Indonesia,
which he published in
the mainstream press,
in the leading news
weekly of the Philippines,
the Philippines Free Press, in 1966.
He had a sense of the scale of
what had occurred in Indonesia.
He referred to nearly a million dead,
and then he wrote a political assessment.
And his political assessment
was that this was the opening
of a revolutionary period in Indonesia,
an extraordinary claim, historically seen.
But one in keeping with the
sort of volunteerism of Maoism,
you know, the paper tigers and whatnot,
sort of it's all in the willpower.
And his claim was that for
every dead Indonesian Communist,
there were four aggrieved
family members and friends
who would rise up, and
that in taking power,
Nasution and Suharto, had made
several critical mistakes.
And among those, he
claimed they had alienated
certain layers of the national bourgeoisie
who had been tied to Sukarno.
Again, that class, the
national bourgeoisie,
that faction of the capitalist class.
And as a result, these
layers would be driven
to armed struggle.
Sison genuinely thought in
1966, in the middle of 1966,
with nearly a million
dead members of the PKI,
that quote, the struggle for power
in Indonesia is far from over.
One doesn't forget a line like that.
The struggle for power
in Indonesia was over
for a very long time, it
did not really reemerge
until the 1990s one might
say, and when it did,
there was not a communist party
on the landscape to speak of.
Sison's argument, however, was in keeping
with the perspective of the CPP,
which he founded in
'68, '69, which claimed,
martial law is good for revolution.
Fascist dictatorship
is good for revolution.
This remains the line of the party.
I gave a lecture in March at Berkeley
on the subject of a bombing
in the Philippines in 1971,
analyzed the events and its significance.
And at the time I was denounced furiously,
by the China, by the Communist party
of the Philippines, and by Joma Sison.
And Sison made a speech the
week that I gave my lecture.
In which he said, and
I quote, the best thing
that can happen for the
Philippine revolution is
for Duterte to impose
a fascist dictatorship.
He will be finished in a year or two.
This, there's a continuity here,
repression breeds resistance.
And so the line of Sison
in the formative layers
of the CPP was that the repression
in Indonesia would foment and accelerate
a revolutionary upheaval.
It's a fundamentally bankrupt
perspective in my opinion.
And one that in some ways says
that the best communist
is a dead communist.
It's a terrifying perspective,
but that was the response to the events
in '65, '66 in the Philippines.
- We have a question from Adrian Vergara.
- [Adrian] Can you hear me?
- Yes, we can hear you great.
- [Adrian] Good afternoon to everyone.
I'm actually from, I'm
actually a graduate student
from the Philippines and I recently read
the first Scalice's work,
early, earlier this year.
It's his dissertation.
- Sorry, sorry to jump in, I'm
having trouble hearing you.
Is it possible to get a little
closer to the mic, perhaps?
- [Adrian] Okay, okay,
can you hear me now?
- Yes, thank you.
- [Adrian] Yep, so I
read your dissertation
earlier this year.
My question is less about the presentation
and more about your scholarship
on the Philippine Communist
movement as a whole,
because recently, I'm sure
you're aware of Rigoberto Tiglau.
I have seen him selectively
cite the research
to push forward a certain narrative
that justice, that justifies martial law.
How do you feel about this as a scholar?
And as a scholar, how
does one defend his work
against, against the co-optation
to promote certain narratives
that justifies authoritarianism?
- Yes.
Thank you very much for that question.
Let me, let me explain the
context of the question
for the larger audience
and then respond to it.
I, but I appreciate this opportunity
to present my own perspective,
as it's a critical question.
History in any country
has profound resonances,
but seldom is that quite as clear
as in the Philippines around
the question of martial law,
the question which will not go away.
Particularly with the rise of Duterte.
Now, a former leading member
of the communist party
named Bobi Tiglau, he was the head
of the Manila Resolve Regional Council
of the Communist party in the early 1970s.
Subsequently broke with the party,
became ambassador to Greece
under the Arroyo administration,
and then a very prominent apologist
for the Duterte administration
on the front page of the Manila Times
over the course of the
last four or five years.
This another point that
I guess should be made
for an international audience.
The character of the Duterte
administration has been one
of unbridled authoritarianism
and death squads.
The estimates are hard to come by,
but it seems likely that over
30,000 people have been killed
by the death squads unleashed
by the Duterte administration since 2016.
A staggering figure, one that begins
to raise questions of genocide.
It's, it's an extraordinary figure.
And Tiglau, drawing on
my doctoral dissertation,
which he cited on the
front page of the Times
in a series on the so-called
Scalice Revelations,
cited my scholarship and
pointed out correctly
that I had highlighted a relationship
between Ninoy Aquino,
the opposition figure,
and the Communist party.
And then included, concluded,
fundamentally twisting my analysis,
that martial law was therefore
warranted and justified.
Something that I have
fundamentally opposed.
Anyone who reads my scholarship knows
that I respond with horror
to the martial law administration.
And that my scholarship is dedicated
to a remarkable extent for a scholar
to try and to use history as a means
of preventing the
recurrence of such events.
I have repeatedly spoken out against this
on Facebook and so on, I
don't have a front page column
in the middle of the Times with which
to trumpet my perspective,
but I published a statement
that was widely circulated
just a couple of days ago
because Tiglau was once
again coming to the fore
because Bongbong Marcos,
Ferdinand Marcos Jr. has
effectively announced his
candidacy for president
of the Philippines and
is, terrifying to say,
a viable candidate in the
sense of could get elected.
And one of the key components
of the social media launch
of his campaign was to misuse
my doctoral dissertation
to claim that martial law was warranted.
And no scholar wants to
be in such a position.
My doctoral dissertation
has now been downloaded
almost 15,000 times for
very, very strange reasons.
So allow me to respond,
having created the context.
I fundamentally and without
any reservation denounce
the misuse of my scholarship
to in any way claim
that martial law was justified.
What Tiglau scandalously leaves out is
that Marcos was himself
allied to a communist party.
And that's a critical
element of my analysis.
And then attempts to twist this
into a justification for
military dictatorship.
My entire argument is how
dictatorship can be avoided.
And my point is that the two
rival communist parties allied
with the rival contenders for the throne,
subordinate the entire
movement and defense
of democracy behind the
aspirants to dictatorship.
It was this, this diffusal and betrayal
of the movement for the defense
of democracy behind anti-democratic forces
that in the end made martial law possible.
To oppose the threat of dictatorship,
I would argue there is the need
for the political independence of workers
from every layer that's looking
to coordinate some new
form of authoritarianism.
And that is my response to Tiglau
and the apologists for Marcos.
And thanks for the chance to clarify that.
- Thank you for that clear
response and the context,
it's a fascinating and
clearly at the center
of a lot of discussion in
the contemporary Philippines.
Does anyone want to ask
any further questions?